- [Tutor] What we're
going to do in this video
is give ourselves some practice
in the first step of u substitution,
which is often the most difficult
for those who are first learning it
and that's recognizing when
u substitution is appropriate
and then defining an appropriate u.
So let's just start with an example here,
so let's say we wanna take
the indefinite integral
of two x plus one times
the square root of x squared plus x, dx,
does u substitution apply
here and if it does,
how would you define the u?
Pause the video and try
to think about that.
Well, we just have to remind ourselves,
that u substitution is really
trying to undo the chain rule,
if we remind ourselves what
the chain rule tells us,
it says look, if we have
a composite function,
let's say f of g of x,
f of g of x and we take
the derivative of that
with respect to x,
that that is going to be equal
to the derivative of the outside function
with respect to the inside function,
so f prime
of g of x
times the derivative
of the inside function,
of the inside function
and so u substitution is all about
well, do we see a pattern
like that inside the integral?
Do we see a potential
inside function, a g of x,
where I see its derivative
being multiplied?
Well, we see that over here,
if I look at x squared plus x,
if I make that the u, what's
the derivative of that?
Well, the derivative of x
squared plus x is two x plus one,
so we should make that substitution,
if we say u is equal to x squared plus x,
then we could say du dx,
the derivative of u with respect to x
is equal to two x plus one,
if we treat our differentials
like variables or numbers,
we can multiply both sides by dx,
which is a little bit of
hand wavy mathematics,
but it's appropriate here,
so we could say two x plus one times dx
and now what's really interesting here
is we have our u right over there
and notice we have our
two x plus one times dx,
in fact it's not conventional
to see an integral
rewritten the way I'm about
to write it, but I will,
I could rewrite this integral,
you should really view
this is the product of three things,
oftentimes people will just view the dx
as somehow part of the integral operator,
but you could rearrange it,
this would actually be legitimate,
you could say the integral
of the square root
of x squared plus x
times two x plus one dx
and if you wanted to be really clear,
you could even put all of those things
in parentheses or something like that
and so here,
this is our u
and this right over here is our du
and so we could rewrite this as being
equal to the integral
of the square root of u,
'cause x squared plus x is u,
times du, which is much
easier to evaluate.
If you are still confused there,
you might recognize it if I rewrite this
as u to the one half power,
because now we could just
use the reverse power rule
to evaluate this
and then we would have
to undo the substitution,
once we figure out what
this anti derivative is,
we then would then reverse substitute
the x expression back in for the u.